Well, I was about seven, and we traveled by car to Benidorm;...
...me and my family including my grandparents and my cousins,...
...and we stayed in a hotel, and one morning,...
...or two days before we were going to leave,...
...my grandad looked through the balcony...
...and asked my dad if he'd moved the car in the middle of the night.
And my dad said, "No, the car should be there."
And my granddad was like, "Well, it's not in the parking lot."
So, my dad went down to look for it...
...and they spent about three hours in the morning looking for it, and it wasn't there.
So, our car had been stolen...
...and so they went to the police, and because they were talking in English,...
...the police couldn't understand them, so it was a bit of a mess.
And we had to go back on a bus, which took about two days, so we had to leave early,...
...and it was kind of a mess, and we never found our car.